avec le françois la france en effet fait
connaissance d'un phénomène celui des
fanatiques ce qu on raccourcit on
appelle les fans s'ils étaient présents
un peu partout des claude françois
arrivé il était là dans les studios de
télévision dans les salles de spectacle
il était là tout le temps de jour comme
de nuit devant le domicile aussi du
chanteur les fans ce n'est pas un
phénomène nouveau vous le savez rudolf
valentino avait les siens mais il cela
était d'un style peut-être tout neuf de
l'adoration muette en était passé en
effet à l'exhibitionnisme et peut-être
parfois à l'excès
75 millions de disques vendus en 15 ans
1500 cas là à travers la france un
physique de petit prince dei
prématurément et un dynamisme débutante
à son premier bal
voici claude françois di cloclo l'idole
des petites françaises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une nuée de fistules chaque déplacement
de claude françois
certaines passent des jours entiers à
l'attendre et nuit à dormir sur son
palier qui sont elles des folles d
hystérique
une d'entre elles meriam s'explique dans
un livre tout ce qui vient de lui et est
merveilleux puisque automatiquement si
je vous aime tous qui vient de lui et
merveilleux rien il y en a jamais assez
chaque jour c'est un jour nouveau ce
n'est pas la même chose pourtant c'est
toujours le même mais chaque fois de
choses on n'est pourtant que vous donne
très peu
bah oui je ne demande pas beaucoup ce
qui me donne c'est déjà bien
ça dure depuis combien de temps ben j'ai
vu en 11 ans quand j'ai commencé à le
découvrir
et puis j'en ai 20 alors ça fait neuf
ans l'airé pourrait durer durer encore
combien de temps va tout à vie parce que
maintenant je sais que ya que lui qui
compte on se raccroche à n'importe
quelle forme d'idéal les uns jardy des
autres jouent aux cartes les troisièmes
au cinéma les autres peigne et ses pieds
des filles qui se raccroche à un symbole
quelconque un artiste du tout quelque
chose qui brille ou quelque chose qui a
l'air de toujours heureux d'être
toujours en forme et des et de refléter
si vous préférez une forme de bonheur
dans la société
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]